let's just take you straight to doha
where qatar's foreign minister is
hosting his dutch counterpart to talk
about the issues of afghanistan let's
just listen
coordination in order to cooperate
with regards to these developments
namely political and in terms of
security
with the paramount importance
as the protection of the civilian
residents
preservation of freedoms and also
preservations of the resources and
assets
of the afghan people we are all hopes
that
the transition of power will be peaceful
without any repercussions negative
repercussions on the afghan people we
also
discussed
the means to address the humanitarian
conditions on the ground
and
how to address
the issues of assistance and other
developmental
aids to afghanistan and the necessity
to bring the whole world community
together behind this issue qatar has
always been
exerting maximum effort to streamline
and to provide all a system possible
with respect to the evacuation of
foreign
citizens from afghanistan together with
the vulnerable afghan citizens
together with those afghan citizens
willing to leave an eligible too
we reiterate that we will continue to
exert these efforts with all the
international players
we also discussed the means to bolster
our
cooperation with respect to
combating terrorism
namely with respect to and after the
recent developments afghanistan
thank you uh your excellency and good
morning the representative of the mania
i'd like to express my appreciation to
you yourself and we hail the
pivotal role played by qatar as always
and qatar is still playing this
instrumental role once again we thank
you for this role as not only with
regards to the backstage negotiations
but also on the international arena with
other
important and significant issues we also
commend the rule played by qatar with
respect to
provide maximum protection to the dutch
civilians who
were evacuated from afghanistan together
with the vulnerable afghanis
i mainly commend
the ability of qatar to maintain
up channels of communication often and
providing maximum assistance to all the
international players including
netherlands
i reiterate what the his excellency said
that our bilateral relations are based
on mutual trust
and cooperation at the international
level we discussed in detail the
situation the latest development in
afghanistan and i can echo what he said
that afghanistan should not be left to
go back as a
breeding ground for terrorism this
is
what we have inside and within the same
context we examined all the
conceivable means where we can ensure
the safe
passage and the safe exit of
all the foreign
citizens including the dutch together
with other afghan vulnerables who are
illiterate
of afghanistan not only the humanitarian
situation which of course is of grave
concern we've discussed the importance
of continuous aid and humanitarian
assistance in a proper and transparent
manner using the right organizations
for our for our for us the netherlands
that would be the united nations or
non-governmental organizations whom we
have worked with before but i've also
asked arthur to employ its influence and
contacts to really help all parties in
afghanistan to reach an inclusive
political agreement that ensures
stability and future prosperity of all
people in afghanistan and of course
we've discussed situation of the
vulnerable position of religious and
ethnic minorities and afghan women and
girls and we would like to contribute to
this process and i've also asked his
excellency very kindly
to to agree to the relocation of the
netherlands embassy from kabul to doha
so the kingdom of the netherlands can
remain effective be in touch uh and
resume its work in the optimal manner
last but not least uh we've also uh
discussed all the progress made
on issues of of of neighbor rights
working conditions um getting ready for
the world cup and i can only wish um the
state of qatar uh and and everyone here
that's worked so hard that the world cup
will become a very
good success and will speak to all the
progress made
under the leadership
of the emir thank you thank you
under the leadership of his excellency
the emmy
i would like to ask about the
humanitarian conditions on the ground
afghanistan
the
former
parliament
member has joined her family members
here in doha
especially we need a brief on the
conditions of women
who are now
bracing for an uncertainty in the future
with the latest statements made by
taliban once again is women's right on
as an item listed on
the agenda of the international
players and also with respect to the
negotiations taking place with taliban
we also would like you to brief us on
the conditions
and prospects of children
and children's rights
who are the most vulnerable
categories there
another
question
about the evacuation process
succeeded in evacuating thousands
of foreign citizens
along with afghan citizens are these
evacuation process
or
still
underway especially that the deadline
was yesterday
it's longer than our statements
the question is even longer than our
statements respectively
if you allow me
with respect to the first part of your
question about
the
[Music]
safe passage of
the
parliament member and her arrival to
doha and women's condition
in general
an extensive part of the negotiations
that took place in doha whether between
taliban and other factions
was centered on women and women's role
we reiterated that women's play a vital
role in the society
this was
emphasized especially that
the majority of the negotiating team was
made up of women
we reiterated to taliban that they
should
carefully review their policies and
rhetoric and narrative towards the women
and also should
reconsider and re-address the issues of
women's right and allow them to take
effective and active role
and enjoy
full and maximum
right to exercise all the rights
and taliban should not back down on what
they had
promised
here for qatar as an example qatar is a
muslim country and women are playing a
very important role taking active
part
uh in every domain in our society 50
of the workforce and the government are
women this is an example
for taliban and others especially that
qatar is a muslim country like that of
afghanistan
where
women
should and can
take active part and this is part of the
tenets of our religion where islam urged
us
to do so
with respect to the
human aid and assistance
and other development mean assistance
in the joint meeting this morning we
discussed the necessity to continue
to deliver
aid
namely through the un
organs
we should not back down in this respect
however the big question is
what are the channels through which such
assistance could be provided
as of now
we can we did not see
any decline in the pace of assistance
provided by the un organizations nor
were they boycotted or rejected by the
afghan
parties and this is very important and
this is also part of the ongoing talks
with taliban
on our part qatar will continue with its
promises and pledges with respect to the
human aid
intended
as respect to the other part of your
question as you know qatar has
provided maximum assistance to all the
allies
and friendly states many of their
subjects have been evacuated directly to
their homeland
or
through
doha here in qatar
we have always urged
taliban to preserve the freedom of
movement
and to provide safe passages to all
citizens foreign
and nationals including the uh afghan
who are eligible to leave
or those holding visas
uh to leave the country
this will be ensured until the airport
is fully operational once again
where the movement will go back to
normal
the same applies to other foreign
visitors who are willing to come to
their homeland maybe i can
take it in three different points you
may know that on thursday friday the eu
ministers of foreign affairs will meet
and afghanistan of course will be a very
important topic of conversation one of
them is indeed to discuss the
conditionalities we've issued statements
on what we'd like like to see for
afghanistan what we expect of the
taliban that means an inclusive
political process inclusive
representation respect for universal
human rights particular regard for the
position of women and girls and of
course an agenda that is sustainable
inclusive development focused that's a
tall order but the conditionalities are
very important the security council has
also expressed itself
in a recent statement on that matter so
we need to help build and of course as
in life we need to provide the
assistance where possible we need to do
that for the sake of the people of
afghanistan
not for any government or particular
regime we do it for the people of
afghanistan what we need to see of
course is that programs and projects
will be implemented that girls can go to
school that young women and girls can
work that their safety and individual
protection is
assured or guaranteed in a proper manner
these are all steps that need to be
demonstrated so it needs to be tangible
the statements is one thing
but as they say in english the proof of
the pudding is in the eating and it's
extremely important
ultimately as well a stable and secure
afghanistan is of interest not only to
the countries of the region it's also
important when we look at european
countries
disorderly or flows of irregular
migration where people may be smuggled
may be trafficked
may face significant journeys of huge
distress is also
harming people ultimately so we need to
have a focus and sharp agenda i think
under the right conditions the european
union and all the member states
including the kingdom of the netherlands
will be generous
this is a shared agenda its intent and
intentions
equally so the political process is very
hard for us to
assess at the moment i think qatar again
will play an important role
as other countries in the region i'm
continuing my journey to pakistan and
later tomorrow to turkey
to ensure that we are in contact with a
number of countries that are
directly assessing the situation that
are either on the ground or have the
right continuous channels of dialogue
and that we really
engage
on the future of afghanistan as one
international community i believe that's
extremely important
good morning thank you for taking my
question i think actually the question
will be for both of you it will be the
same question but maybe the answer might
be a bit different
what do you think
qatar can obtain from the taliban that
other countries cannot
and how do you see your role in the next
few years
in the new regional situation
thank you
well
i think that
qatar approach
with the taliban is along with our
international partners and our regional
partners and
we've been
talking with them through
[Music]
the mediation process in consultation
and also in collaboration with the
with other partners and allies and also
we continued that role during the
inter-afghan
dialogue that
we were having
a lot of countries were trying to help
and to support the process which took
place
in doha
i won't say that qatar can obtain
something that others
cannot i'm sure
each country has its channel of
communication and has its ways of of
communication with bodybuilding but
being
also
a
fair and neutral
mediator in in the past few years
between whether it's between taliban and
uh
the us or uh
and and uh and the other uh afghan
parties
has built uh a trust with all the afghan
parties not only with paribas and
this
investment that
resulted with this trust i think we need
all to use it
in a good way for the good of the future
of afghanistan
well um i think it's it's a tough
question to ask perhaps of the
netherlands we've always been a partner
to the people of afghanistan but we've
done so in
uh
joining the uh the military missions
that have been
implemented in the past and of course we
were part of
operation resolute support but alongside
we invest 50 60 million euros a year
in sustainable development and
humanitarian assistance
for the people of afghanistan i think i
can only load
the state of qatar for its patients
for its stance on mediation and efforts
continuous to
provide the platform and the channels
where the parties that need to talk to
each other
can talk to each other and that's
extremely important in international
diplomacy exclusion is easy inclusion
requires a lot of patience and
commitments and i think we all look
towards qatar and i'm sure you'll see a
number of government plays land and take
off land and take off and that's i think
the best recognition any government can
have in terms of its role and the
expectations of his role so i wish you
uh
and continuous engagement because i
think we all look towards qatar for the
leadership role it has played thank you
so much